die us-arzneimittelbehörde fdp
bezeichnet es als einen historischen
schritt zum ersten mal überhaupt
weltweit ist eine gentherapie gegen
krebs zugelassen worden
erst einmal nur in den usa aber europa
könnte noch in diesem jahr nachziehen
die eigenen immunzellen werden hierbei
gentechnisch so verändert dass sie
selbst zu tumor jägern werden und gegen
den krebs kämpfen die medizin setzt
große hoffnung in diese gentherapie wie
hoch die heilungschancen sind und ob
dies der entscheidende schritt im kampf
gegen den krebs ist jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen es
ist wirklich absolut bahn brechen
konkret geht es um die therapie namens
camera des schweizerischen
pharmakonzerns novartis ende august hat
die us-arzneimittelbehörde fdl diese
gentherapie auf dem amerikanischen markt
zugelassen mit ihr sollen zunächst
einmal blutkrebs patienten also leukämie
patienten aus den usa unter 25 jahren
behandelt werden für die es keine
anderen chancen auf heilung
die sogenannte akute lymphatische
leukämie kurz ll
in deutschland macht sie fast ein
drittel aller krebserkrankungen bei
kindern und jugendlichen aus hierbei
entarten die vorläuferzellen der
lymphozyten also der weißen
blutkörperchen und vermehren sich
unkontrolliert die krankheit ist wenn
dann überhaupt nur mit intensiver
chemotherapie in den griff zu bekommen
medizinerinnen und mediziner weltweit
setzen große hoffnungen in die
gentherapie cumbria in tests mit 63
krebskranken jungen menschen bei denen
andere therapien erfolglos ausgeschöpft
wurden habe kümmerer in 83 prozent der
fälle wirkung gezeigt innerhalb der
ersten drei monate so die angaben des
pharmaherstellers novartis bei elfte
erkrankten schlug die therapie nicht an
bei 29 patienten und patientinnen trat
der blutkrebs nach sechs monaten wieder
auf trotzdem ist dieses ergebnis
erfolgreicher als andere therapien die
bislang angewendet werden die idee
hinter der kamera therapie ist
tatsächlich beeindruckend körpereigene
zellen eines blutkrebs patienten werden
hierbei so umprogrammiert dass sie
selbst gegen die krebszellen kämpfen
sie werden also zu tumor jägern
tatsächlich eine völlig neue dimension
in der mitte
10 zunächst werden den betroffenen
bestimmte immunzellen entnommen die
sogenannten t zellen im labor werden
diese dann gentechnisch so verändert
dass sie in der lage sind krebszellen zu
identifizieren und zu zerstören dies
funktioniert durch genmanipulation
hierbei binden die t-zellen einen
bestimmten rezeptor an ihrer oberfläche
wodurch sie ein spezielles antigen auf
den tumorzellen erkennen sie werden
vervielfacht und dem patienten und
patientinnen dann wieder als infusion
verabreicht sobald die t-zellen
krebszellen identifizieren greifen sie
an und vervielfältigen sich wieder
absolut genial denn so kann allein eine
gentechnisch veränderte t zelle tausende
tumorzellen vernichten erwartet
beziffert die kosten für diese therapie
auf 475.000 dollar also umgerechnet rund
400.000 euro für den hohen kosten kommen
starke nebenwirkungen die auch zum tod
führen können die gentherapie wird
deswegen zunächst nur in speziellen us
fachzentren durchgeführt den patienten
und patientinnen wird dann zudem nur
eine sehr geringe menge an t-zellen
verabreicht um zu überprüfen wie stark
ihre reaktion darauf ist und auch hier
in europa stehen die chancen gut dass
diese gen therapie zugelassen wird
darüber zu entscheiden hat die
europäische arzneimittelagentur ema und
ihr liegen schon anträge dazu vor
experten und expertinnen hoffen dass
tausende schwer kranke menschen bald
davon profitieren können bei allen
bedenken gegen die in therapie manche
medizinerinnen und mediziner sprechen
tatsächlich schon von einer neuen ära
der leukämie behandlung dieses
faszinierende prinzip der so
produzierten tumor jäger soll möglichst
bald auch auf andere arten von krebs
übertragen werden aufgerüstet
immunzellen könnten dann auch
tumorzellen in brust- lungen- oder
bauchspeicheldrüse bekämpfen
doch dies ist leichter gesagt als getan
das problem hierbei die t zellen haben
es viel schwerer solche festen tumoren
zu erreichen
zudem ist das milieu in diesen bereichen
des körpers ungünstig für sie wenn es
hier fortschritte gibt oder
komplikationen hierbei clixoom hat sich
euch natürlich dazu auf dem laufenden
wenn er kein video zum thema noch zu
allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann
wird mir ja ein aber aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den
die glocke hier geht es weiter mit krebs
mit smartphone diagnostizieren soll
funktionieren wie klickt auf das video
damit ihr nicht um stärkt also ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran